cinq établissements au départ un seul
sacre et à l'arrivée le rugby-club de
versailles organisé hier sa 2e édition
du tournoi des lycées de versailles
c'est d'abord un clin d'oeil à
l'histoire du club de versailles c'est
que le club des centenaires et en 1893
le rugby est né au lycée hoche à
versailles
et si aujourd'hui depuis toujours le
rugby à versailles et sa horde lycées et
donc le slogan à versailles c'est pas
rugby études ses études puis rugby poule
de milliers final un tournoi de rugby à
7 complet pour désigner le meilleur
lycée de la ville près de 90 joueurs ont
foulé la pelouse du stade de
porchefontaine les petites concurrences
enfin on a un peu on a peu mis à
l'épreuve mais disons que c'est pour le
plaisir quoi c'est plutôt pour retrouver
les copains et prendre du plaisir
ensemble un tournoi pour transmettre les
valeurs du rugby créer de nouvelles
équipes et pourquoi pas se faire repérer
par les entraîneurs du club